welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A I know
this is one of my favorite programs
because I've always liked hearing the
answers rather than asking the questions
and I don't know which is the easiest
but just for me that works want to
introduce you to our Our Guest Our 3abn
Guest we're a long ways from California
right now we're in Southern Illinois we
have Pastor James raffy James welcome
well good to be here JD yes you are a
long way from California but it's so
nice to have this modern technology and
it's so nice to join you here for the
3abn Q&A Bible Q&A amen and then to my
right is my precious beautiful wife
Shelly oh boy Shelly welcome to to the
Bible Q&A it's always a joy we just want
to thank those of you at home for
sending in your questions and it's so
much fun to get in the Bible and and try
to figure out what to give you in a
short amount of time to answer that but
we thank you for your participation we
do this for you but we get blessed amen
and of course Shel brought up the fact
that these questions come from you and
so how do they come to you or how do
they come to us from you and that is
three ways one is by text so if you want
to use a text to send it in to us at
283975 you can see it on the monitor
there perhaps you'd rather email it if
you'd like to email it it's Bible
QA 3ab
bn. and if you would like to use
Instagram it's 3abn uncore official
that's the three ways to get your
questions to us we love having your
questions Shelly can we have an open
Pray by you certainly
certainly our glorious Heavenly Father
we come before you today with
Thanksgiving in our hearts we praise you
for your Plan of Salvation we praise you
for who you are and what you've done to
save us and Lord thank you for this
opportunity thank you that you gave us
your word that you reveal yourself to us
through your word and we pray now that
your Holy Spirit Will anoint our lips
Come Holy Spirit be our teacher and let
each one of us who are hearing these not
only just learn head information but
help it Lord to settle in our hearts and
that we might put your word into
practice we love you we thank you we
Praise You In Christ we pray amen amen
amen thank you want to share something
from PSAL Psalms Psalms we all love
Psalms so let's go to Psalms
119:
105 your word is a lamp to my feet and a
light to my
path absolutely fantastic there's
nothing worse than being caught out in
the dark with no light
here is the light this is from this is
Jesus himself talking to us sharing his
thoughts being interpreted by those that
are inspired to put it into writing
James we're going to start with
you I think this is going to be a six
minute question okay it is six minute
answer what time answer that's
right what time in history does Isaiah
66 verse 24 occur what is the full
meaning of this verse and where and to
whom are they
speaking that is a great question and
it's it's one that is challenging that's
why I wanted to take a little bit more
time to answer this first let's start
with the verses in Isaiah 66 let's read
Isaiah 66: 22- 24 and it begins here and
it says for as the new heavens and the
new Earth which I will make shall remain
before me says the Lord so shall your
seed and your name remain and it shall
come to pass that from one new moon to
another and from one Sabbath to another
shall All Flesh come to worship before
me says the the Lord and they shall go
forth and look upon the carcasses of the
men that have transgressed against me
for their worm shall not die neither
shall their fire be quenched and they
shall be an uphor unto all flesh Isaiah
66 2223 and 24 so really want to
understand what's taking place in these
verses because on the one hand you have
the new Heaven and the new Earth
everyone coming to worship God and on
the other hand you have what looks like
the suffering uh and Punishment of of
the the Lost uh the carcasses of men
that have transgressed against me well
it really does all sort out when you
look at the big picture Revelation chap
20 and 21 gives us an overview of what
takes place after the 1,000 years and
this is really the same history that
Isaiah 64 or 6622 to 24 is talking about
another place we can see this is in
Isaiah 28:4 to 21 but in Isaiah in
Revelation 20 we have the
second coming of Jesus Christ the Saints
are resurrected to heaven and then a
chain is placed on Satan he's Bound by a
chain of circumstances to this Earth all
the wicked are slain all the righteous
are in heaven the Earth is laid desolate
for 10,000 years during that time we are
worshiping the Lord from one Sabbath to
another from one new moon to another we
are worshiping the Lord we are praising
God however there is still going to be
this event that takes place sometime
after the 10,000 years when the new
Heaven and the new new Earth comes down
to planet Earth planet Earth is
recreated so the New Jerusalem John saw
coming down to planet Earth in
Revelation 21 and in Revelation 20
there's a resurrection of the wicked and
they surround the city of God and
there's going to be a punishment that's
going to take place that's described in
Isaiah 66: 24 that even though we've
been worshiping the Lord and coming
before him every Sabbath now we're going
to go forth and see the destruction the
punishment of those who transgressed
against the Lord and that takes place in
accordance with the decrees of God that
have been worked out through the
Thousand Years Isaiah 28 brings this out
more clearly if you want to look at
Isaiah chapter 28 just look at verses 14
to 21 this is describing this
resurrection and the punishment of the
wicked it says wherefore hear the word
of the Lord ye scornful men that rule
this people which is in Jerusalem
because you have said we have made a
covenant with death and with hell we are
in agreement when the overflowing
Scourge shall pass through it shall not
come unto us for we have made lies our
refuge now let's pause there for just a
second this is indicating that there are
a lot of people who believe there's no
future there's no judgment there's no
God when you die you die and the grave
and the the the the ground is the the
resting place for eternity forever we
have made a covenant with death we are
in agreement with hell and we will not
be resurrected and God says no that's a
false Refuge of Lies you've hid yourself
in lies therefore thus says the Lord
behold I lay in Zion a foundation stone
a tried Stone a precious Cornerstone a
sure Foundation he that believes shall
not make haste judgment also will I lay
to the line and righteousness to the
plummet and a hail the Hail shall sweep
away the Refuge of lies and waterers
shall overflow the hiding places God is
going to call forth all from the grave
the righteous who go to heaven and the
wicked who face the judgment and your
with death Isaiah 28 goes on to say
shall be disal and your agreement with
hell shall not stand when the
overflowing Scourge shall pass through
then you shall be trotten down by it and
then notice what it says here in Isaiah
28 from the time that it goes forth it
shall take you for by Morning Morning by
morning shall it pass over by day and by
night and it shall be a vexation only to
understand the report for the bed is
shorter than a man can stretch himself
on it and the covering narrower than he
can wrap himself in it for the Lord
shall rise up in Mount parison and he
shall be wroth as in the valley of
gibian that he may do his work his
strange work and bring to pass his act
his strange act this is the punishment
of the wicked the resurrection from the
grave and notice it takes days and
nights it doesn't end in just a few
moments because the punishment is
different based on the crime based on
the as it says in Romans the reward the
wages of sin is death and there's a wage
that each one one is heaping up against
this day this final day of judgment and
Punishment Isaiah 14: 12-20 also talk
about this specific to the devil but
Ezekiel 28:16 through1 19 is really
interesting when it talks about how
they're going to look upon the carcasses
and the fire that cannot be quenched it
says here speaking of Christ by speaking
of the Devil by the multitude of thy
merchandise they have filled the midst
of thee with violence and thou Hast
sinned therefore I will cast thee as a
Fane as profane out of the Mountain of
God I will destroy the O covering cherub
and from the midst of the stones of fire
thine heart was lifted up because of
thine Beauty thou has corrupted thy
wisdom by reason of thy brightness
therefore I will cast thee to the ground
I will lay thee before kings that they
may behold thee thou has defiled thy
sanctuaries by the multitude of thine
iniquities by the iniquity of thy
traffic therefore I will bring forth a
fire from the midst of thee it shall
devour Thee I will bring thee to ashes
upon the Earth in the sight of all all
them that behold thee all they that Know
Thee among the people should be
astonished at thee Thou shalt be a
terror and never shalt thou be anymore
this is really solemn but it's really a
beautiful promise that God is making to
us that he's going to destroy sin and
sinners those who refuse to accept God's
gracious invitation to Salvation and the
last one that will be destroyed with a
fire from the midst of them will be
Lucifer the arch deceiver the author of
Lies the author of sin and and death
death amen wow very good it's very very
good Shelly your first question before I
ask that you might get out a pen uh
pencil and paper or pen and paper
because there is a lot of scripture
today Shelly can you explain Exodus
23:
20-23 who is the Angel and this is from
Norma in Florida Norma this is a great
question and to understand the point or
the angel of Exodus
23:20 through 23 we have to understand
the context the context begins in Exodus
20 verse 22 through Exodus
23:33 and what is happening here God
dictated a systematic code of civil
social and ceremonial religious laws to
Moses
and then this is to be the new
constitution for the new nation of
Israel with God as their Sovereign King
so Moses chronicled these terms in
Exodus 20 verse 22 through Exodus
2333 and then he records them in what
the Bible calls the book of the Covenant
you find that in Exodus 24 7-8 so he he
record records them in his own
handwriting on parchment and what these
promises included were the conditions
for God's presence to go with the nation
of Israel into the promised land and it
was key to their Victory so what you see
when you get to Exodus
23: 20- 23 these are some of the closing
verses of the book of the Covenant
listing the conditions for God to go to
the promised land let's look at it
Exodus 23:
20-23 and he says behold I sent an angel
before you to keep you in the way and to
bring you into the place which I have
prepared beware of him and obey his
voice do not provoke him for he will not
pardon your transgressions for my name
is in him but if you indeed obey his
voice and do all that I speak then I
will be an enemy to your enemies and an
adversary to your adversaries for my
angel will go before you and bring you
into the amorites Hittites parasites
Canaanites hivites hivites however you
say it
jebusites and I'll cut them off so
here's the first thing you need to
understand the word in the Hebrew is
Malik m a l a
k and it is translated just as many
times
messenger about an equal times Angel so
the word Angel is the messenger of the
Lord and When God says my angel or the
angel of the lord we believe many Bible
scholars believe this is the
pre-incarnate Christ and I believe that
this is proven in within context of the
Bible Jesus was not Jesus till he was
given that name at his Incarnation when
he took on flesh he was the
co-equal person of the godhead and he
frequently appeared as the angel of the
Lord for example in Exodus 313 and 14
when he appears to Moses the angel of
the Lord in the burning bush and then
Moses asks his name and the angel of the
Lord says I am am who I am thus you
shall say to the children of Israel I am
as sent me to you the interesting thing
is the Angel of the Lord is always
distinct from the father and he never
appears again after the Incarnation when
the person of Jesus Christ was born so
question Exodus 23 20 through 23 these
are the Clos losing verses of the book
of the Covenant my angel my messenger is
the messenger or Angel of the Covenant
let me read to you quickly two verses
Malachi 3:1 behold I send my angel my
messenger and he will prepare the way
before me and the Lord whom you seek
will suddenly come to his Temple even
the messenger or the angel of the
Covenant in whom you Delight so the Lord
is the messenger who comes the angel who
comes into his Temple and then he says
behold he is coming says the Lord of
hosts and then my personal favorite
Isaiah
63:9 in their Affliction in all their
Affliction he was afflicted who is the
he the angel of his presence saved them
in his love and in his pity he redeemed
them the angel of the Lord is Our
Redeemer and he bore them and carried
them all the days of old amen very good
sh very good James your second
question as Christians we believe the
whole Bible to be infallible word of God
how would you respond to the people who
say that the Bible has been changed and
this is from Nick and
Kenya thank you Nick and Kenya that's a
great question you know there's a Bible
verse in Matthew 5:25 and it says agree
with thine adversary quickly while thou
are in the way with him and the word
adversary means an opponent especially
Satan in the Greek and of course
answering this question really depends
on who is saying that the Bible has been
changed and just what the inference is
because we could say yes in a way the
Bible's been changed there's no need to
defend that or try to defend that fact
uh it's been changed in the fact that we
have hundreds of versions of the Bible
today in fact there are according to
google
3,141 versions of the Bible and each
copyrighted version will vary from a
previously copyrighted version in order
to avoid plagiarism so you're going to
see changes in some cases and that are
minor and then you're going to see
changes in other cases that are pretty
blatant meaning that they have no
support in the original
Greek text or manuscripts Revelation 1:1
for example has been uh changed from the
Lord's day to Sunday in no less than
nine newer translations of the Bible
that is post 2020 I always like to use
that example because it's so easy to
find so just because we have all these
changes does not necessitate the
conclusion that the reliability of the
Bible has changed you know the devil
would love to have us come to that con
conclusion there are some very reliable
versions of the Bible available for our
study today and I think the most
reliable this is in my opinion is the
good old KJV it's kind of harder for
some people to read but it is not
copyrighted it is great manuscript
history coming from the texus receptus
and not the alexandrian text West C for
and ness's manuscripts it's very
accurate theologically though it does
come with some flaws as humans were used
by God in the production and of course
in the translation from the Greek but
there were some 47 of the best biblical
Scholars of the day who worked on the
KJV to produce this translation so we
can see that the word of God is still
available to us in its purest form to
this day in fact in fact God is promised
to preserve his word and I think that
there's a number of versions including
the KJV that are a fulfillment of This
Promise notice what it says in Psalm 119
and verse 89 it says forever O Lord Thy
word is settled in heaven God is not
going to let his word be so changed or
so lost or so forgotten that it will not
be available for those who honestly seek
to understand what God has communicated
to us he has protected his word in fact
Jesus says in the New Testament Matthew
chapter 24 4:35 Heaven and Earth shall
pass away but my words shall not pass
away now of course Jesus was speaking of
the words concerning the signs of his
coming and the end of time but we can
take the principle here and recognize
that just as Jesus promised that he
would preserve the words of warning he
gave to his disciples and to us just so
God has promised to preserve his Bible
and to keep his Bible for us today we
have a more sure word of Prophecy the
Bible says now more recently they
discovered uh the Dead Sea Scrolls and
these Scrolls uh verify that the words
that have been translated down through
the years the Old Testament at least uh
are almost 100% accurate to what they
found in these Scrolls that were
hundreds and hundreds of years old so we
can know with assurance that God has
protected his word he's delivered his
word to us in the uh Dark Ages Satan
tried to uh do away with the word of God
to burn it uh to keep it locked up
chained up to a Pulpit to keep it in the
hands of the clergy only and not out to
the common people once the word was
translated by Luther and Wickliffe and
others now Satan has tried to produce so
many different versions of the word of
God that it we get confused about what
the word of God is actually teaching and
meaning either extreme is seeking to
pull us away from what God has preserved
so that we can understand the truth that
will never pass away that will be
protected and that can deliver us safely
into the kingdom of God Amen I just want
to add one thing for me I I can't read
the new king I mean the old King James
version because my mind just won't go
there so like the new King James version
is still a literal translation some of
the words that were changed were because
they found more Greek manuscripts and
and with each arot every time the
archaeologist finds something more we
get a little bit understanding better
understanding of some words there are uh
literal translations there's Dynamic
translations like the NIV or I like the
Amplified so I think what you do and
what I do as well James is we look at
several different versions as as you're
studying I like to study nasb I like to
look at the new king I still go to the
King James quite often but it's
something that the word of God the
message of God hasn't changed that's
right
amen Shelly your second question when I
ask God for help with a specific
question how do I know if I hear his
voice with the answer I have an answer
but how do I know it's the right answer
and this is from Terry oh Terry I love
this question because what this tells me
is you you are trying to tune into the
still small voice of the Lord in First
Kings 19:12 we've we in context we've
got Elijah who after Jezebel he's run
from Jezebel he's up hiding in the
mountains and there is a fire a wind and
the fire and it says the Lord's not in
the fire and then there's an earthquake
and the Lord's not in the earthquake and
all of a sudden Elijah hears the still
small voice of the Lord I believe the
still small voice of the Lord is when
God impresses his thoughts upon our mind
it's not an audible voice when God spoke
audibly it's compared to the sounds of
many Waters
so I do think Christians should learn
it's okay to listen we should be
listening in John uh 10 and verse 27
Jesus said my sheep hear my voice they
know my voice I know them they follow me
so let me give some for some who may not
be quite as advanced as you are let me
give uh several points and then we'll
see how to confirm this if you want to
hear God's voice you've got to seek his
face you're seeking his presence in
Psalm 27
7-8 I love what David says here oh Lord
when I cry with my voice have mercy on
me and answer me when you said seek my
face I said Lord your face I will seek
so what we're doing is fixing our mind
on the author and finisher of our faith
we are we're focusing on Jesus we are
drawing near to God so that he can draw
near to us as James 4 says but remember
we've got to submit to God be willing to
be open to follow his lead secondly seek
his Enlightenment Paul told the
Ephesians in chapter 1 and verse 18 he
he was talking about having the eyes of
their heart flow flooded with light so
that they could know and understand his
plan for them so when I'm seeking the
Lord I'm praying Lord flood my heart
with your light seek Stillness what do I
mean Psalm
4610 God says be still and know that I
am God so to be still means quit
striving let your mind and your emotions
be still
the sources of our thoughts they're
either coming from self or they could be
coming from Satan or the holy spirit so
what I find is that I'm not so much
worried about what Satan because I'm
pretty much where I get to know if it
doesn't line up with God's word if it's
making me feel condemned and guilty I
know that's Satan's voice but boy being
still in my own mind and knowing it's
not my voice that's a challenge
so the fourth point is seek his will not
yours you know when Jesus was in the
garden Luke
2242 he's praying and he says oh Lord
let this cup pass from
me but then he says not my will but
yours be done that's got to be your
attitude when you come before the Lord
and we've got to test the spirits as
first John 41 tells us to do which means
anything you think you're hearing check
it against scripture because scripture
is the number one way that the Lord
speaks to us the holy spirit will never
impress a thought upon our mind that
violates
scripture five stand watch I mean be
patient in habach 2 1-3 habach says I
will stand my watch and set myself on
the rampart I will watch to see what he
will say to me and what I will answer
when I'm corrected you know that's often
I'm I'm going before the Lord and saying
Lord if I need correction correct me I
invite his correction because it's
gentle then and then he goes on the Lord
answers him and says write the vision
and make it plain on tablets that He who
reads it may run with it the vision is
yet for an appointed time but it at the
time of the end it will come it will not
te
though it terries wait for it because it
will surely come it's not a light it
will not t now number six oh you know
Isaiah let's add Isaiah 30:21 in here
that's a great great promise to claim
Isaiah 32 says 21 says you will hear a
voice behind you saying this is the way
walk in it whether you're turning to the
left or the right now you're asking how
do I know for sure you've got to seek
confirmation first as I've already
mentioned it has to line up with
scripture but there's something that I
believe that is important and that's to
have a trusted friend if you're seeking
for something a trusted Christian friend
that you know isn't going to just speak
off the top of their head but someone
that will pray about God's answer to you
Proverbs 11:14 says where there's no
counsel people fail but in the multitude
of counselors there is safety I always
pray Revelation 37 that says he says
there that Christ is the one who opens
and no one can close and who closes and
no one can open so I'm praying Lord open
the way or close the door and let me
know for certain um I personally don't
put out fleeces I did once and you know
what the Lord said this time time I will
give you a sign I I think sometimes
fleecing is not an Act of Faith Hebrews
11:6 this is number seven you got to
stand in faith to trust him Hebrews 11:6
says without faith it's impossible to
please him you got to believe that he
exists and that he rewards those who
earnestly seek him as Proverbs 3:5 and6
says trust in the Lord with all your
heart do not lean on your own
understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He will direct your
path amen good answer amen I love that
amen that's great just a quick reminder
how do you send your questions into
3abn number one is if you'd like to text
that's 618 228
3975 perhaps uh email that's Bible QA at
3ab .tv our Instagram is
3abn
official James number three question all
right can you please explain 2
Thessalonians
2:11 what does it mean that God shall
send them a strong delusion and this is
from darthy from
Alabama hi Dorothy that is a very
significant question you know biblically
speaking this phrase
God will send them strong delusion can
be understood in two ways number one uh
that God honors free choice and gives us
up to the delusions that we choose or
number two that truth itself which God
has sent to us can become a strong
delusion or snare if we reject it now
this phrase can also be understood in a
way that is not biblical suggesting that
God literally sends strong delusion to
people so that they will lost and then
God simply doesn't do that because we're
told in second Peter chap 3 and: 9 God
is longsuffering usw not willing that
any would perish or that all that but
that all would come to repentance so
we're going to look at a couple of
examples from the Bible First of all we
want to look at Pharaoh there are two
ways that we can understand the phrase
that God hardened Pharaoh's heart now
this first is to recognize that the word
hardened means to strengthen to seiz
upon to conquer and to encourage that's
what the word means in the Hebrew the
second is to recognize that everything
God did to encourage Pharaoh was
rejected and through the process of
rejection Pharaoh's heart actually
became hardened in a sense by God
because God initiated the heart
hardening process by giving Pharaoh
evidence of his power which Pharaoh
rejected so in the second understanding
Pharaoh's response to God's Miracles
that at first convinced him to let his
people go let the Israelites go LED
pharaoh to ultimately refuse the
Miracles that God worked and thereby his
heart was hardened the process involved
God working on Pharaoh's heart and in
this way God says that he hardened
Pharaoh's heart and this same basic
process exemplified by Pharaoh is
repeated in every single human heart
every single human being who ultimately
rejects light and faith and love and
grace and life and drawing power of God
I mean those are all the things God does
for us he gives us light John chap 1
verse 9 he He Loves Us John 3:16 he he
draws us John 12:32 he gives us a
Measure of Faith Romans 12:3 he gives us
Grace Titus 2 and vers 11 all of these
if they're rejected our hearts are
hardened and we become less suceptible
to the drawing influence of the grace
and Light Of God so there's no clear
biblical evidence to support the idea
that God purposely literally hardens
people's hearts so that they will reject
him God just doesn't do that it would
not be wise for us to use this one
scripture to come to that conclusion
about God's character without taking a
deeper look at the process that is
outlined in the Bible especially in the
life of Jesus Christ himself so let's
just look at the process with Christ and
the Jews and in Isaiah chapter 8 there's
a prophetic declaration regarding Christ
and what he the truth truth would become
to those reject who rejected him this is
what it says Isaiah 8: 13 and
14 sanctify the Lord God of hosts
himself and let him be your fear and let
him be your dread so letting means or it
uh suggest the choice are we going to
choose to let God be our fear let him be
our dread and he shall be for you a
sanctuary but for a stone of stumbling
and for a rock of offense to both the
house of Israel for a Jin and for a
snare
to the inhabitants of Jerusalem now
that's the opposite he's not going to be
a sanctuary to us if we reject him he's
going to be a snare he's going to be a
Jin now the Hebrew word Jin is simply a
spring net the root meaning is to spread
a net the Hebrew word for snare is a
noose for catching animals with a root
meaning to ins snare in other words what
God is to some people a sanctuary a
place of safety a refuge he is to other
people he becomes a snare or a new in
the case of pharaoh Moses the man
through whom God wrought directly became
a snare to Egypt because Pharaoh refused
the light from God that was revealed
through those miraculous plagues in fact
in Exodus 10: 7 notice what it says it
says and Pharaoh's servants said unto
him how long shall this man that is
Moses be a snare unto us that's the word
that is used there let the men go that
they may serve the Lord their God
knowest not now yet that Egypt is
destroyed that's again Exodus 10:7 now
the word snare that is used here to
describe God's work through Moses is the
same Hebrew word employed in Isaiah 8:14
describing Christ's work as the Lamb of
God to the Jews so Moses and Jesus both
became a snare to those who would not
receive the truth and Psalm 69: 20-23
basically tell us the same thing first
of all it talks about Christ's suffering
for us and then it says in verse 23
those who for those who rejected Christ
let their table become a snare before
them and that which should have been for
their welfare let it become a trap let
their eyes be darkened that they see not
and make their loins continually to
shake that's Isaiah 6923 so the table
the bread of life became a snare to the
Jews that which should have been for
their welfare the Messiah became to them
a trap and so the scripture was
partially fulfilled in John chapter 6
where Jesus identifies him as the bread
of life and says You must eat My Flesh
and drink my blood and the the Jews that
rejected him and even some of his own
disciples who wouldn't accept that
saying they turned from him and they
became his worst enemies now their
choice to reject Christ turned into a
snare for them and to them Christ became
a delusion his claim to be the Messiah
became a delusion to them they actually
persecuted him and put him to death
because he claimed to be the very thing
he was there's no greater delusion than
that so just in closing because we're
running out of time here just a summary
here so that we can um leave this
without confusion Jesus became a
stumbling block to those who rejected
him a stumbling block is not a good
thing something that the Bible warns
Believers not to become don't become a
stumbling block Paul says in Romans 14
and 1 Corinthians 8:9 yet to the Jews
who would not receive the truth Christ
became a stumbling block in this way
truth Jesus becomes a stumbling block or
an occasion of apostasy when it is
rejected so here's the simple outline
God sends light to every man first John
1:9 man makes the choice to accept the
reject the light John 3:9 if rejected
the very light becomes darkness and a
stumbling block or an occasion of
apostasy Luke
11:35 wonderful great great explanation
that was really thorough that's good
Shelly you're number three okay what is
meant by begotten in the Bible was Jesus
created or has he always been oh this is
such a great question and I'm sorry I
don't have longer to answer Micah 5 and
verse
2 it's in this prophecy it says you
Bethlehem
EPA though you are little among the
thousands of Judah this is the
birthplace of Jesus yet out of you shall
come forth to me the one to be ruler in
Israel whose goings forth are from of
old from
Everlasting
Jesus was not created he is the creator
of all things there was never a time
that he didn't exist Philippians 2: 5-7
says let this mind be in you that was in
Christ Jesus who being in the form of
God he was God did not consider it
robbery to be equal with God because he
was God but he made himself of no
reputation humbling himself to
become um human being and coming in the
likeness of men Colossians
2:9 says Paul says in him in Christ
dwells the fullness of the godhead
bodily he was perfectly God and
perfectly human Titus 2 and verse 13
Paul says that we are looking for the
Blessed hope and the Glorious appearing
of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ
this is speaking of the same one he is
Jesus Christ is our great God and savior
John 1 1 through3 John says in the
beginning was the word the word was with
God the Word was God he was in the
beginning with God all things were made
through him nothing that was made was
made without him so our creator who
created all things was not himself
created John 1:14 then says the word
became flesh dwelt among us we beheld
his glory the glory as of the only
begotten of the father full of grace and
full of Truth
aha Jesus is the only begotten of God
what does begotten mean to be can
literally mean to give birth to but not
in Covenant language in Covenant
language which is employed you know when
Jesus said boy you got to know the
writings of Moses or you won't
understand my
message what Moses does is we see in the
first five books of the of the Bible all
of these Covenant terms are introduced
and God God calls the children of Israel
his firstborn son that's Covenant
language he says he begot them in 1
Corinthians 4:15 Paul uses this Covenant
language and to be begotten means to be
chosen for a covenant purpose so Paul
says to the Corinthians though you might
have 10,000 instructors in Christ you
don't have many fathers for in Christ
Jesus I have begotten you
through the gospel so Paul is telling
the Corinthians they were begotten by
him he's not talking about giving birth
to them pH Fon 1:0 he writes to Fon and
he says I appeal to you for my son
onesimus whom I have
begotten while in my chains Paul wasn't
onesimus father he had chosen him for a
covenant purpose Hebrews 11:1 17-19 is
the most convincing Hebrews 11:17 by
faith Abraham when he was tested offered
up Isaac and he who had received the
promises offered up his only begotten
son what do you mean Abraham had eight
sons and we know that ishmail was his
firstborn son in the natural biological
order of things then he had another six
Sons with coutura but here's the point
only begotten is Covenant language and
it means the unique One of a Kind Son Of
Promise who's the only heir to promise
he was chosen by God so it says uh he
offered up his only begotten son of whom
it was said in Isaac your seed Shall be
Called concluding that God was able to
raise him up even from the dead from
which he also received him figuratively
so Jesus Christ is called the only
begotten Son of God because he's one of
a kind he's the only one chosen to be
the last Adam There's No One Like Jesus
acts 13
32-33 says we declare to you glad
tinings that promise which is made to
the fathers God has fulfilled this for
us their children in that he raised up
Jesus as it is also written in the
second Psalm you are my son today I have
begotten you Hebrews 1:5 repeats that
God says you are my son today I have
begotten you some Bible scholars believe
that Jesus was
incarnated or begotten excuse me that he
was begotten at the resurrection some
believe that he was begotten when he was
incarnated but here's the one thing that
I've got to share with you when we are
children of God Sons and Daughters of
God we are begotten 1 Peter
13-5 says blessed be the Lord God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ who
according to his Mercy has begotten us
again to a Living Hope through the
resurrection of Jesus Christ from the
dead to an inheritance Incorruptible and
undefiled that does not fade away
reserved in heaven for you who are kept
by the power of God through faith for
salvation ready to be revealed in the
last time good good amen good amen great
answer James your last question can you
please explain Revelation 1213 to 17 and
this is from Pinda
I fenda thank you for the question
Revelation 12 uh uh 13 to1 17 let's just
read the verses and see what we can
understand from these verses it says the
dragon was wroth excuse me and the
dragon was cast into the Earth and he
persecuted the woman which brought forth
the Manchild and to the woman were given
two wings of a great Eagle that she
might fly into the Wilderness into her
place where she's nourished for a time
times and half a time from the face of
the serpent and that serpent cast out of
his mouth water as of a flood after the
woman that he might cause to be carried
away of the flood and the Earth helped
the woman and the Earth opened up her
mouth and swallowed up the flood which
the Dragon C cast out of his mouth and
the dragon was wroth with the woman that
was the verse I was trying to read and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
so the dragon here is the devil right
this is symbolic language and verse 9 of
Revelation 12 tells us the dragon is
that old serpent the devil and Satan and
it says that he's cast into the Earth
that means he's no longer able to
deceive the unfallen worlds the Heavenly
Angels this is referring specifically to
the Cross he was cast out Jesus says in
in John chapter 12 I'm going to cast The
Prince of this world out so he was cast
out at the cross lit literally yes we
know he was cast out uh at the fall at
the Great War that took place in heaven
according to Revelation 12 7-9 but but
spiritually he was cast out in the sense
that he was defeated by Christ at the
cross and the woman represents God's
Church Old Testament New Testament we're
told that a woman is a symbol of a
church we're told that in Ephesians
chapter 5 and also in 2 Corinthians 11:2
Isaiah 1:21 the Manchild represents
Christ that's verse 5 the Eagle's Wings
are God's Provisions or protection
according to Exodus 19:4 he takes his
people into the promised land of Canaan
with Eagle's Wings so we see God uh over
and over again Psalm 91 where to gather
under his wings protects us with his
wings and then the Wilderness is a place
of Refuge from persecution the times
times and a half a time is a 1260
prophetic day or literal year Dark Ages
time when uh the woman was seeking to
escape from persecution the water
represents persecution according to
Isaiah
9:15 and the persecution that came
against the woman sought to destroy the
church during the Dark Ages and the
woman fled Into the Wilderness for first
in the European uh Wilderness and then
over the ocean to North America and that
is the earth the earth is the place
North America is the place that
swallowed up the flood of the Dragon the
flood of persecution and allowed the
woman to be established and to have uh
religious liberty as well as civil
liberty and we see that in Revelation
13311 where the lambik or the Beast with
lamb likee horns comes up out of the
earth we know that represents symbolizes
American prophecy the Earth North
America and then we have the remenant
now the the the the the dragon is angry
with the woman and goes to make war with
the remnant those are the ones who look
like the woman who's clothed in the
righteousness of Jesus Christ that's the
sun standing on the uh Moon that's the
word of God he makes war with them
because because they believe and are
closed with Christ's righteousness they
keep the Commandments of God and they
have the testimony of Jesus Christ I
want to just do a shout out for our
program salvation symbols and signs we
have a study study number 52 you can
watch that study on salvation symbols
signs on 3abn and you can get all this
information and more and plus there are
free study guides that you can download
amen amen thank you so much shelle I'm
going to read this quick due to time can
you explain 2 Timothy 3:16 we've heard
arguments against it like what does the
word scripture really mean the disciples
didn't have the Bibles we now so how did
that that they knew that their letters
would be part of what we call scripture
okay 2 Timothy 3 3:16 and 17 all
scripture is given by inspiration of God
is profitable for Doctrine for reprove
for correction instruction and
righteousness that the man of God may be
complete and thoroughly equipped for
every good work so to which holy
writings was Paul referring he was
referring to the entire Old Testament
The Works of Moses the Psalms and the
prophets and by
implication he included New Testament
writings and I'll prove that to you
these writings were already circulating
and already considered sacred scripture
although they were not yet a collected
work Jesus actually affirms the entire
Old Testament as scriptures in Luke
22:44 45 he said these are the words
which I spoke to you while I was still
with you that all things must be
fulfilled which were written in the law
of Moses and the prophets and the Psalms
concerning me that is the accepted
definition of the entire Old Testament
during his day the law of Moses the
Psalms and the prophets now in second
Peter chap 3 and verse 15 we find that
Peter says consider the longsuffering of
Our Lord he's going on and he's talking
about Paul and he says hey some some
people twist his writings because he
writes some things that are hard to
understand which untaught and unstaple
people twist to their own stru
destruction as they do with the rest of
the scriptures so basically here's what
we're finding we'll find that they are
compared the New Testament scriptures
are compared to the Old Testament 2
Corinthians 5:18 you find that uh Paul
is talking about Deuteronomy and Luke
putting the two on par wow you both can
talk
fast it's so good it's good stuff I want
to take just a few minutes here and for
an address roll and then we'll be back
close us out okay God
bless if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA 3abn.org
[Music]
and then watch 3an Bible Q&A for answers
from God's
word welcome
back James we're going to pick up with
you we got probably about two minutes
left do you have any additional thoughts
or comments yeah I think it'd be good to
go back to that question about strong
delusion I think it's one that we
struggle with I just wanted to emphasize
that God is not sending strong delusion
God is sending light he's sending truth
he's sending the gospel but when men
choose not to receive the truth and the
love of the truth it becomes a snare or
a stumbling block or an occasion
apostasy the devil leads people who
choose to reject truth to be ins snared
by the very idea of the truth that the
very truth then becomes a stumbling
block or leads them to Ay let me let
just give an illustration about this um
you ever talk to someone about the
Sabbath or the law and you know they
they're convicted and then all of a
sudden they go to their Pastor or you
know watch some program and they come
back completely different they say oh
that old Sabbath that was for the Jews
not the Christians or that law it was
nailed to the cross or everyone knows
you go to heaven when you die I mean
this happens all the time and then those
people start thinking that you're
deceived about the truth when the very
truth itself is rejected by them they
become deceived by that rejection so you
know that Sabbath was for the Jews death
is that you know death is like asleep is
is sleep heresy and obedience to law
that's legalism you know so the truth
itself now becomes strong delusion
people fight against the truth and
they're completely deluded by that truth
that they have rejected thinking that it
is error thinking that it is wrong not
realizing that the Sabbath is a time of
close fellowship with God the law is a
transcript of God's character Soul sleep
is the best way for God to manage the
Wags of sin until the Judgment all of
the truths of God's word proceed from
the heart of the kindest wisest being in
all the universe yet when we reject it
the truth itself becomes uh the
rejection of that truth itself become
strong delusion the same sunlight the
light that melts wax hardens clay so the
light of the word will either melt your
heart and you fall in love with the Lord
or it will harden your heart amen
needless to say I just want to thank you
for spending this time with us I hope
that uh you were blessed just want you
to know that at 3abn we love each and
every one of you and we only wish the
best of the best of days to you
[Music]